two friends who think they are
metalheads enter a band contest but
their friendship is in trouble when they
get involved with a girl who seems to
have metal in her veins more than the
two of them put together
today on cinema recapped i'll show you
metal lords
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the movie begins with a couple of guys
called hunter played by actor adrian
greensmith and kevin played by actor
jayden libre who are practicing their
music in the style of metal rock
rehearsing in the room of one of them
hunter plays his guitar very excitedly
but when kevin starts playing the drums
the other boy stops him telling him that
he's somewhat out of tune kevin admits
that he only knows how to play the drums
at school hunter comments that they need
a bass player as one would be a great
help to the band the next day at school
kevin is playing as drum when the
teacher stops him and tells a girl named
emily that she needs to improve in
certain aspects because of this the girl
explodes and insults the teacher she
also throws the flute aside and leaves
the place
where kevin watches her and thinks that
because of the way she spoke to the
teacher she has metal in her veins
later kevin explains that they want to
be the best in metal since that way they
would be very popular in school and
people would praise them as gods
he also explains that hunter has been
his best friend for a long time since he
always protects him later one of the
jock boys at school is about to knock
kevin down hunter tries to warn him but
he doesn't understand what he's saying
and ends up on the ground
his friend picks him up while they hear
that the popular kids are planning a
party that night the two friends
infiltrate the party where kevin drinks
a lot he tells hunter that he's going to
the bathroom but he runs into a
beautiful girl and he starts talking to
her since he's drunk and therefore not
shy
at the same time we see some guys
picking on hunter they hit him a couple
of times and some instruments get broken
then hunter gets annoyed and tells the
guys who played at the party that they
don't know anything about music he also
says that he has a real band so they
invite him to sign up for the band
competition which will be soon the next
day hunter signs his band up for the
contest
they go and buy a new drum set using a
card he took from his father
later when kevin was about to practice
he hears that emily plays very well
hunter annoys one of the popular kids
because of what they did to him the
other day
then they quickly flee in the car and go
through an alley so the others do not
reach them since they're driving a big
truck hunter gives kevin a list of
popular songs to practice and he makes a
copy of it and secretly sends it to
emily
she investigates and begins to get more
into that style of music days go by and
after making a lot of effort kevin is
becoming very good at the drums while
emily watches him over and over again
until one day she decides to talk and
practice with him
together they make very good metal music
at school
the boys who bullied earlier gag hunter
and cut off a lock of his hair
later we see that he had to shave one
side to match his hair but he likes it
like that since he looks like a bassist
he was in the band of metallica named
jason neustet the boys auditioned to
find a bass player but only one shows
who is very crazy and doesn't even know
how to play the instrument
kevin insisted emily should join them
since she's very good although hunter is
stubborn that she's not a good image for
the gang and rejects her emily receives
a call from kevin they both confess that
they've never done it and that they
don't want to continue like this so the
girl tells them to meet her at a place
to do it when they arrive at the greed
upon place they shyly get into the
girl's truck and do their thing because
of this kevin is late for rehearsal with
hunter so the friend scolds him and
calls him a loser while kevin decides to
leave before he says more insulting
things
later kevin is playing his drums while
another boy listens to him and tells him
that he's very good and invites him to
join them in a different band even if
it's only for the weekend since they're
playing at a party kevin says it'll
think about it kevin and emily get along
very well as they begin to fall in love
the next day hunter makes an extreme
explanation of metal but focuses on
women repressing rock in men all
indirectly pointing to emily so that she
leaves his friend alone and therefore he
can concentrate on the band however the
girl explodes like she did with the
professor before
she chases after him to beat him up
shortly after hunter is in detention and
also somewhat beaten since the girl gave
him what he deserved then the two
friends of a fight and kevin says that
hunter needs him more than he needs
hunter and that if they separate he
could have a normal life with emily in
the afternoon kevin reassures emily
telling her that nothing has happened
that was her fault since hunter is
insane does not know how to deal with
people
he ends up hugging the girl to calm her
down
meanwhile hunter dresses and paints his
face like a rock star while the father
tries to stop him since he considers it
ridiculous
but the boy ignores him and leaves the
house at the same time kevin is with the
band that invited him to the party where
he plays very well and catches the
attention of some girls
hunter tries to go to this party as well
but he's easily stopped by a guard
meanwhile the leader of the other band
congratulates kevin since he was
spectacular he invites him to join them
to participate in the band contest and
kevin says that he'll think about it at
the same time hunter was arrested and
his father went to get him out but the
police consider his belongings to be
weapons and confiscate them the father
says that he knows that he stole money
from him to buy the drums so he will
enroll him in a hospital
in which he will have to be locked up
the boy tells his father that he won't
be able to since the band contest is
coming soon but the father tells him
that he has no choice meanwhile kevin is
with a very beautiful girl who admires
him because he plays very well
so she starts kissing him at that moment
the boy imagines some rock stars give
him good advice but also others who give
them bad advice
in the end kevin decides to pay
attention to the one who tells him to
respect emily so he leaves the party
the next day hunter is at the help
center where he meets dr nix whom the
boy quickly recognizes because he used
to play in a very popular band
nix tells him that he's no longer in the
group because he ruined it by not
knowing how to live with his companions
the man asks him if he drinks or smokes
but hunter says no to both so the doctor
considers him healthy and lets him go at
least until next week hunter knows he
won't make it to the battle of the bands
and he worries about it
at the same time kevin agrees to play
with the other gang although he calls
his friend first but he doesn't answer
then he calls his home and his father
tells him everything
later kevin goes to emily asking for
help to get hunter out of that place but
she doesn't want to so she starts to get
upset and the boy tells her that it's
okay that he'll take care of it kevin
arrives at the help center infiltrates
the facility and finds his friend who
wants to apologize but the boy tells him
to do that later since he turns on the
fire alarm to escape
and they also take another young man
with them who was once in a band hunter
apologizes to emily for everything and
asks her to please join them in the
battle of the bands but she refuses
saying that she's not ready yet later
they arrive at the event where the other
guys are and kevin apologizes to them
and tells that he can't be in two groups
at the same time
but he also says that he brought his
replacement who's a very good drummer
hunter also apologizes to the other
young man since he's been very mean to
him before
shortly after the boys are preparing to
enter the stage but they're worried
since they're missing a bass player and
their songs will sound a little weird
however that moment they see emily
arrive
she's dressed for the occasion and is
ready to accompany them in battle
although the person in charge of the
event tells them that the name of their
group had bad words but the girl changes
the last minute so they end up being
called skull flowers
they go on stage where they see that
nobody knows them and the audience is
very quiet
but they don't care and start playing
and everyone starts listening to their
songs which are very good because of it
everyone grows excited and starts
dancing to skull flowers but hunter has
a little accident
he falls and one of the heavy speakers
crushes him breaking his leg the days go
by and we see the band rehearsing hunter
still has his leg in a cast and his
father enters to congratulate them since
they won second place in the battle of
the bands later they find out that they
went viral in the newspapers and we see
them being very happy with what they've
achieved together
we also noticed that the three of made
along very well the end if you liked the
video please leave a like and subscribe
to continue receiving recaps of the best
comedy movies
thanks for watching